what are your core beliefs about
pursuing a writing career
that's like huge um
that is and what i mean by huge is like
there's so many things there um the the
the the main thing is um
for me is you just have to be
committed and you have to have passion
as a as a writer
regardless of what genre of writer
writing you're working on
i think that first and foremost
that you have to consider yourself
a writer not a screenwriter but rather a
writer that's just me some people might
say i'm otherwise but you really have to
consider yourself a writer because if
you don't
understand how
how
how to take writing out of the re the
arena of solely just um crafting um spec
scripts um pilots for tv and um and
feature screen plays you're never going
to really develop
some innovative skills
and actually doing those things
that catch people's you know attention
so i think that's very important so
that all falls under the ballpark of
commitment and passion
um
so that means that you basically you you
you need your your friend is a
is like um
is a cup of coffee
and
your
your your seat
in front of that you know the computer
screen those are your friends
and you
better get comfortable with them you
know um
[Music]
because
you're going to need them
you know you have to you have to spend
the time
um to to learn to do
what you want to do and also
this is the other thing
you know um it's an excavation
um
and it's not an excavation of the
of the work that's in front of you per
se although it can be
it's an excavation of yourself
because you start to realize
who you are
as a writer you start to realize that
like let's say like you know we're using
a
a baseball um
analogy you throw a mean curveball
you know you start doing you go oh wait
wait i throw them being curveball you
know it's like um well let me let me
work on that a little bit you know sort
of thing so um
that that's what you start to learn
about yourself but first you you might
you might you know just think you're
just a good shortstop
you know when you begin you know before
you discover your own
peculiar talents
when was that clear to you
um
that's an interesting uh question
and um
[Music]
that's gonna be fun to talk about um
when that was clear to me was um
i i um
i
when i started writing in general
wrote a lot of poetry and i enjoyed
writing poetry and
the craft of writing poetry
and so
i thought that maybe
it would be easy to use what i know from
from poetry writing
uh to
to develop um
writing screenplays
i i
i wrote my first screenplay and i had
the great fortune to
to meet and
for a short period of time
um receive some mentorship from from a
guy who
who took a little bit of interest in me
a director from old school from old
school hollywood
named ted post
and he was very
very gracious and generous to
to offer to read my first screenplay and
[Music]
he read it and he got back in touch with
me
and he said to me goes
christian you know i gotta tell you you
know it's like
i think you got some talent
i think you know how to write some
dialogue but you have no idea how to
tell a story
it's like and i'm like oh wow okay
gee well tell me what you really do
exactly you know but thanks you know and
he's like i want you to go out and i
want you to buy this book
and
um
i i bought this book
called the art of dramatic writing the
most important book i
one of the most important books i should
say and i've
read in terms of my writing
definitely the
the book that helped set me off on
on the journey
um by lalos agree i hope i'm pronouncing
that correctly and um
and um
the book is um
is not so much about um
writing for the movies as it is the the
classical elements of telling story as
it relates to
um
to the plays of ibsen shakespeare
um even
a
a few more modern plays of of the of the
early um the early
20th century um such as
o'neill's plays and whatnot
and
that really started to break down for me
what i understood to be
structure
but
even then
i was still a bit flummoxed on
how to find a
a way
to have a confidence
when i would attack a screenplay
because i was like okay there's this
over here and
um i have i think i have a good idea of
of of voicing characters and and writing
you know interesting dialogue
but i'm
not so sure how to marry the two
so i had written in one script
and um
and
some people were responding to it
um
pretty well and almost like a lukewarm
fashion but they were like oh it's you
know it's got a middle a beginning a
middle and an ending
and
i um i stumbled across um
a copy of shane black's the long kiss
goodnight
and
i noticed
specifically
how
shane
wrote his screenplays
um
these um
terse little bursts
of
of word formations
to
to convey
the atmosphere
of um
of the of the action lines and the
descriptions of each scene
um
just it was just so exciting to read
that
and to
and how
it was and how
how he sort of
just kind of like broke rule certain
rules not like not broke rules just to
break rules but just
broke
certain rules so that he could
he can meet certain dumb um objectives
in a very
targeted fashion
and
i thought to myself well like i i can do
that that's not
i can i see what he's doing i see the
architecture underneath it
and i can i can definitely do that and
furthermore i found it very
relate a great deal to
to
what it was like to writing poetry
because poetry is often very um
elastic with with with language and with
words and and and and shane's work was
very elastic
so
um
with
with words and sentences and the grammar
was he had paid no attention to grammar
really
um it was just all about getting you to
understand the scene
and so um
i i took that on
and i rewrote that that that screenplay
that i had and then
boom lots of people were all
loved that script um and in fact um
it it it it secured me a finalist
position with um tribeca all
um soon after that and that's when i
knew i was on to something that's when i
realized like
hey
i can do this now i
i know what to do i have
i have all my i have all all the paints
in my um
and my box of paints
so yeah
you